we live in an age where some games just
keep on going with post-launch road maps
advertising months or years of future
content hate em all love em live service
games are here to stay that's kind of
their whole deal in 2021 five live
service games stood out above the rest
implementing substantial improvements to
their existing formula or by finding new
ways to tell ever expanding stories here
are gamespot's 5 best live service games
of 2021
apex legends continued to be a dominant
force in the battle royale space in 2021
the year saw developer respawn release
four new seasons four new playable
characters four new weapons a new mode
new maps and a whole host of balancing
adjustments and changes plus apex
legends finally made its way to switch
it's definitely not the ideal way to
play but it works the new mode arenas is
certainly the highlight for apex legends
year expanding the game outside the
battle royale space with an excellent
mode that resembles valorant in 2021
respawn doubled down on promoting its
own community creating an intriguing new
avenue for how live service games can
tell a story the developer hired members
of the community to flash out the
stories of apex legends with traditional
comics animated comics and 3d animated
videos machines contained this land for
them
that power seduced them
made them weaker
in many cases these artists were
creating the first look and mannerisms
of pre-existing but unseen characters
sure respawn had a guiding hand for
every story but most artists had final
say on what they created making apex
legends into one of the few live service
games where its fans have creative
ownership over aspects of the narrative
too
343 industries may have fully entered
the live service arena in 2021 with halo
infinite but halo's original creators
bungie continued to have a choke hold on
the style shooter space with destiny 2.
destiny 2 had an incredible year the
return of the vault of glass raid new
events the best storytelling the game
has ever seen and so many balancing
changes that we've had a non-stop stream
of news to cover about patches alone
2021 has also been a great year for
destiny 2's pvp the pve side of destiny
2 is always being updated so as
incredible as the updates for it have
been this year it's a payoff of what
bungie has spent years setting up the
same can't really be said for pvp which
doesn't get nearly as much regular love
in comparison that changed in 2021 with
bungie implementing a new system to
further balance team composition in
crucible when folks queue in solo trials
of osiris also relaunched with plenty of
impressive improvements to help make the
skill-based mode less exclusionary and
more approachable for new players even
in a year when destiny 2 had plenty of
cool revelations tied to its pve
campaign the pvp side shouldn't be
overlooked
did you know that the critically
acclaimed mmorpg final fantasy xiv has a
free trial and includes the entirety of
a realm reborn and the award-winning
heavensward expansion up to level 60 for
free with no restrictions on playtime
in all seriousness final fantasy xiv is
just a consistently good game these days
so it's no surprise to see it continue
to attract new players and renew the
almost religious-like vigor that
existing players have for it in 2021
final fantasy xiv continued to excel on
the strengths of its superb storytelling
and rewarding gameplay
more than anything the success of final
fantasy 14 online can be measured by the
launch of its end walker expansion which
saw queue lines so long and aggravating
to wait through that existing fans have
begun jokingly asking for folks to stop
spreading the word about how such a good
game has a free trial in hopes of
preventing the player base from growing
any larger ahead of the next expansion
fortnite has an interesting narrative
through line in the background of its
battle royale which is a truly wild
thing to say when you think about a game
that started out as a pve experience
where you built forts to prepare for
zombie attacks at night most of 2021 saw
fortnite expand throughout its chapter 2
before undergoing a massive overhaul in
the final month of the year with the
start of chapter 3. chapter 3 added a
whole host of new content for players to
enjoy including a brand new map new
gameplay mechanics such as sliding and
plenty of new cosmetic skins like
spiderman fortnite is a game built on
the shoulders of others implementing
successful gameplay loops and mechanics
from other games to improve itself 2021
proved no different though occasionally
fortnite overstepped a bit and punched
down outright copying from games much
smaller than it like among us
fortnite is a far better experience when
epic games is striving forward with
unique ideas all its own which we saw a
lot of in 2021 such as its novel way of
injecting its battle royale game with
story missions virtual concerts exploded
with another summer of kids being kept
home on account of the covered pandemic
and though admittedly in far less
successful fashion fortnite also
broached other subjects in its metaverse
like exploring the legacy of martin
luther king jr let freedom ring from
every hill and mole hill of mississippi
from every mountainside
let freedom ring
fortnite is very quickly becoming a
world all its own and that was never
more evident than in 2021
sea of thieves nears the end of its
fourth year as 2021 comes to a close and
the year saw plenty of content drops and
balancing adjustments throughout most
prominent of all is a pirate's life the
pirates of the caribbean tie-in the
developer rare somehow kept hidden and
completely under wraps up to its launch
i'm captain jack sparrow
though since you came here to rescue me
[Music]
looking back it makes sense pirates of
the caribbean is thematically the
perfect crossover for a game like sea of
thieves surprisingly a pirate's life
revealed that sea of thieves is capable
of featuring traditionally single-player
content it's not a seamless integration
but the experience does snuggle into the
pvpe
open world of sea of thieves quite
nicely and has us eager to see what
story driven experience the game will
get next 2021 also saw the start of sea
of thieves season 5. admittedly the new
season started at the tail end of the
year it started on december 2nd but
season 5 has managed to make a splash in
sea of thieves it might sound silly but
season 5 introduced the mechanic of
burying treasure allowing you to hide
away your loot from your friends and
foes alike and if you're feeling
generous you can post the map that leads
to your treasure to quest boards at sea
posts and outposts live service games
that allow players to give back to the
community they love will always hold a
special place in our hearts and we love
that sea of thieves allows us to take
our excessive loot and make new
adventures for friends and strangers to
embark on
it's not just rare making adventures in
sea of thieves anymore it's the players
too
we'll be revealing our top five xbox pc
and playstation and switch games too so
make sure that you hit that subscribe
button so you can catch up on the best
games of the year and speaking of we
also have a deep dive into why death
loop is our game of the year live now
thanks so much for watching
[Music]
you